How do we implement access control
using the access control matrix?
This is what we want to discuss.
So first of all the access control
matrix is going to be pretty large.
There could be tons of resources,
depending on what kind
of system you have.
If it's a large shared server
there could be lots of users.
So it's a large matrix, but we know that
the matrix is going to be fairly sparse.
So sparse matrix here really means
that many of the entries in the matrix
are going to be null.
because most users not going to
have access for a given resource.
Resource is owned by somebody.
He or
she's going to have access to it and
maybe they choose to share
it with a few other people.
So the question is how should we
represent this matrix in the system?
Actually sparse matrices
represented in one of two ways.
You can represent them either
sort of column measure or
row measure and that's something
we can do here in this case.
So we can focus on each
column of the matrix, and
if most of the entries are null
we can just ignore those and
we can make a list that says,
well for object Oi,
user ui1, this user's access
rights are this value.
Okay, so we have these entries, so when
I said matrices, when they're sparse,
they can be implemented
through link list for example.
So this could be a list of, and it's
going to have a small number of entries.
Because most users don't have
any access for object Oi.
So if a given user has access,
what kind of access we can have,
sort of this pair, and
then the user id, and access rights,
that makes up the first
node in our list.
Next user is going to be ui2, who has
some other set of rights, and so on.
So we can just go down the column and
see what users actually have
known null access rights.
And build these entries,
that become nodes in a link list or
something like that.
So we can organize this information
either by a resource or an object.
Here we'll have to keep track of what
users have access to this object, and
what kind of access they have for
this object.
So that's one way to do it.
When you do that,
this list I'm talking about, or
the data structure that we're talking
about which is this collection,
this linked list kind
of a data structure.
That's a collection of these entries,
what user has what access rights.
This is called an access control list or
an ACL.
So if you focus on a resource or
object Oi and
grab the information who has
access to this resource and
what kind of access, that defines
an access control list or ACL.
To keep in mind is that ACLs are for
resources we have in the system.
So ACL is always associated
with an object or a resource.
There's another way to think about
how we can implement it, and
rather than focusing on columns,
we can focus on rows.
And we know that rows
correspond to users.
So we can go down horizontally,
you know, across a row and
say, what would we see.
If it's a sparse matrix, this user
ui is not going to have access for
most of the objects.
But he or
she will have access to some objects.
So the first object we run into for
which ui has access is this object oi1.
So the list we are going
to generate here,
which is going to say for this given
user ui, we do have access and
these are the access rights for
object oi1.
The next object for which we have
access, or this user ui has access is
oi2 and those access rights
are defined by rights2 and so on.
Basically we are ignoring
the null entries in the row, and
the entries that are not null are for
certain objects.
So these are those objects,
and what kind of access for
each of those objects,
that's what we capture in this list.
Well, this kind of a list is
called a capability-list,
in some sense what a user is capable of.
A user is capable of accessing oi1
in this manner, oi2 in that manner,
so it's called a capability-list
that is for a given user ui.
Remember, ACLs are for an object,
capability-lists are for a user.
Again, C-list is going to be associated
with each user we have in the system.
Remember, we have a row in
the access control matrix for
each user, and
each row really is a C-list.
It's a list representation
of what's in that row.
So, C-list are for users.
ACLs are for objects.